why do so many people hate mathematics
very good question I think there are
several reasons the problem is
multi-dimensional no pun intended
imagine that you had to take an art
class in which you were taught only how
to paint a fence or a wall but were
never shown the paintings of the great
masters would that make you not lover
years later you will talk to your
friends and say oh my gosh I hated art
at school I was so bad at it
what you would really be saying is I was
bad at painting the fence and likewise
with mathematics people often say oh I
was so bad at math I hate math but what
they're really saying is I was bad at
painting the fence so how do we make
people realize that mathematics is this
incredible archipelago of knowledge if
you want kids to to understand and
appreciate the beauty and power of
mathematics we have to connect it to our
daily lives let me give an example say
you go on Amazon to buy a book and you
are immediately presented with various
recommendations how does Amazon come up
with these recommendations well there
are sophisticated algorithms at play
which analyze your past choices which
correlate you with other users who are
deemed to have similar preferences then
all this data is is processed and you're
presented with these choices now I'm not
saying that this is necessarily a good
thing
but I think at the very least we have to
be aware of this we have to be aware of
this algorithms invading our lives and
those algorithms are based on
mathematics you and I live in houses and
we appreciate the houses we live in it
doesn't mean we need to know how to lay
bricks that's right
so why just because we're you just
because mathematics is underlying some
of our technologies in our life what
does that mean we have to understand or
even appreciate it that's a very good
point and likewise people say well the
fly airplanes without necessarily
understanding the you know the physics
of flight but there is a difference and
first of all mathematics is part of our
culture just like literature and art and
we have to be able to have a fulfilling
life we have to be aware of this but
also because Mad Max is becoming so
important in our lives there is a lot of
opportunity for misuse of mathematics
and for manipulating us by using highly
sophisticated mathematics there are many
examples of that global economic crisis
was the large extent caused by misuse of
mathematical models which one could
argue often were used by you know
executives of financial firms who did
not fully understand them what if we
lived in a in a world in which a was a
Wall Street executive would not say oh I
don't I don't get this stuff but as long
as it works it's fine what if in fact
that person would say ok tell me more
about it I would like to understand how
this model works it's a great quote a
great German mathematician Georg Cantor
said the essence of mathematics lies in
its freedom but I would augment this
with the following where there is no
mathematics there is no freedom so Mad
Max is essential to our freedom to the
functioning of our democracy that's why
it's not just about finding out how some
things work which you don't need to know
about because you know who cares there
as long as they work I think that our
ignorance can be misused by the powers
that be and for us to put it to be you
know to the citizens in this new brave
new world we have to be more aware of
mathematics we have to know and
appreciate its power for to do good but
also to do well tells us we should
appreciate our more and English
professors will say we need and then
which skills improved computer
scientists or say we need to understand
code the mathematicians are telling us
we should appreciate maths some of the
math huh-huh we only got these finite
brains and only so many hours on the
planet why do you break mathematics
above the others I know you're a bit
biased well first of all I'm a
mathematician right but but also I would
say that art for example is like art so
the station was of course people don't
go to art museums we know that not
everyone goes to that not everyone pays
attention but at least people know that
there are there exist museums if if you
say the word art they don't think about
painting the fence
they think about van Gogh and Picasso
and Leonardo da Vinci so they know that
at least if they whenever if they you
know have an interesting they know where
to go where to find those paintings or
you can go online and find those
paintings right in the case of
mathematics they are not even aware of
the masterpieces of great mathematicians
the way they're aware of the existence
of masterpieces or the great artists art
of course is important because it speaks
about our emotions and speaks about the
world and about ourselves but in a way
one can survive without art but one
cannot survive without mathematics
everything is based on mathematics it is
the language of nature well its portion
some blame let's blame someone then it
sounds to me but you're blaming her
schoolteachers you were saying though
you know yeah back in our school days
we're making us paint fences instead of
showing us Picasso well if I really were
to assign a blame I would assign the
blame to myself and my colleagues
professional mathematicians we don't do
nearly enough exposing these ideas to
the public in access in an accessible
way oftentimes we are not willing to
come up with good metaphors and
analogies and this is how science should
be communicated you have to communicate
science in a way that would you know be
by the way that's creative that links to
something that people already know and I
feel as though other scientists are
doing much better job physicists
biologists we keep talking about the
solar system about the universe about
galaxies about atoms and molecules and
elementary particles and the DNA those
concepts are no more complicated than
things that we do in modern mathematics
why is it that you know DNA and stars
and and and limitary particles are part
of our cultural discourse but
mathematical mathematical ideas are not
well in part because we are not doing it
nearly enough we professional
mathematicians not doing nearly enough I
don't blame the teachers because you
know they're in the precarious and
really an enviable position oftentimes
because they are you know overworked and
underpaid and also teachers themselves
are the product of the same flawed
system
Lucian is that first of all more
mathematicians should go out and and let
other people in on the secret you know
because it's really almost like a secret
and we all and we are almost like this
elite which is sort of keeping that
secret and I don't want that to continue
I want everyone in on the secret I want
everyone to realize that there's this
beautiful world out there which is so
important for our daily lives which
possesses the you know unparalleled
power and beauty we have to convey this
ideas we have to find ways to convey
those ideas and then you know we have to
also work through our education system
we also help have to help teachers to
learn the necessary content and to learn
how mathematics connects the real world
so that they make the study of
mathematics for students more enjoyable
more fun more interesting why does that
not happen it seems so obvious I mean
that's what you said is not like in a
like a huge conceptual leap what is this
already happened why it's not already
happening well sometimes I'm wondering
myself why is the way it has not already
happened it's almost a conspiracy yet I
mean honestly it's almost like there is
a system of mirrors that has been
created which distorts you know the
reality which does not allow most people
to see what's out there
and let's face it I mean how many more
things are left to discover it's you
know we can't be the first to you know
discover another continent like Columbus
we can't be the first to set foot on the
moon but what if I told you that there's
this beautiful world out there and you
don't even have to travel anywhere to
find it it's right at your fingertips
wouldn't you want to go and find out
more about it and if you if you do this
in the right way then you will have
children you have you will have students
you know writing to class not away from
the class but running to class is like I
want to know more I won't find out more
I won't talk to my peers to my
classmates about this stuff this is a
cool stuff in the world that's what it
is
cool stuff in the world and yet everyone
hates it and yet everyone hates it isn't
it ironic if you'd like to hear more
from Professor Frank : about his love of
mathematics this is his book love and
math you can't have this one this one's
mine but you can get your own copy and
one of the ways you can do that is
through the sponsor of this particular
the video audible.com biggest range of
audiobooks you can imagine and one of
them is this one as you probably know by
now you can go to audible.com slash
numberphile and if you sign up you can
download a free book and it could be
this one it'll be the book of your
choice so if you're going to check them
out go to audible.com slash numberphile
and then when it comes time to pick your
free one love and math Edward Franco I'm
sure he'd appreciate it